alors je voudrais revenir très
rapidement pour les raisons pour
lesquelles le sénat dans une très large
majorité
et pour des gélules partie gens
éventuellement de l'économie libérale
comme moi partisan d'une manière
générale de la privatisation comme moi
nous nous sommes opposés très fortement
à la prévisualisation de repos charles
de gaulle tout d'abord il y avait la
durée de la concession anormalement
longue
je rappellerai que pour le tunnel sous
la manche c'était 50 ans il y avait un
risque technologique
il y avait une incertitude des ailes et
économique là on est partis d'entrée de
jeu sont 70 ans
deuxièmement il y avait un argument vous
de la part du gouvernement c'était la
rentabilité des évidentes
pour autant c'est le conseil
d'administration qui est nommé
majoritairement par le gouvernement qui
fixe et cette rentabilité
il va sembler évident de nombreux
interlocuteurs que effectivement c'était
pas un véritable argument
j'avais la faiblesse du prix et surtout
l'incertitude lié à l'eau prix nous
n'avons pas eu pendant ce débat la
possibilité de savoir combien exactement
le gouvernement attendait de cette
privatisation nous a parlé d'une valeur
de 20 à 30 fois la valeur les résultats
de l'entreprise
trente fois lehrer résultats de
l'entreprise pour une durée de 70 ans
c'est un prix extrêmement faible mais ce
prix ne tenait pas compte comme cela a
été souligné par un certain nombre de
mes collègues de l'indemnisation
éventuelle
en réalité il n'ya aucune transparence
sur ce projet du gouvernement
il ya surtout l'absence de consensus des
usagers des clients les compagnies
aériennes
aucune ne le réclame absence de
consensus
des gens qui travaillent dans cette
entreprise c'est un paradoxe dans une
loi qui est normalement
censé améliorer la situation dans les
entreprises
lorsqu'on parle de la raison sociale il
y a eu si une réserve foncière de 7000
hectares une réserve foncière de 7000
hectares dans le coeur de
l'agglomération parisienne le flou le
plus absolu
enfin le projet d'entreprise nous avons
du mal à comprendre si c'est une année
reprise bien gérée par la puissance
publique ou mal gérée comme cela a été
démontré par mon collègue qui a cité les
propos du premier ministre
enfin il y à aussi quand même peut-être
une position de fond c'est une situation
dominante situation dominante dans le
domaine des transports
peut-on laisser ou si l'on fait un
parallèle avec le secteur de
l'audiovisuel les mêmes entreprises
avoir plus de 50% des parkings des
municipalités 50% des autoroutes la
seule liaison tgv express la seule
liaison de tgv concédé et plusieurs
reports sur le territoire national en
réalité il ne s'agit pas d'une mise en
concurrence ça n'a rien à voir avec le
libéralisme
il s'agit de la cession des bénéfices
d'un monopole à une seule entreprise
parce que l'environnement de lente de la
report de la plateforme aéroportuaire
nuit n'est pas assumer financièrement on
sait qu'il faudra sans doute doubler le
trafic autoroutier
il faudra améliorer les liaisons
ferroviaires avec la capitale il faudra
faire des d'importants aménagements
urbains mais là les collectivités
territoriales sont évidemment assez peu
concernés
alors effectivement la solitude du
gouvernement votre propos que j'ai
entendus
c'est à dire le discours du gouvernement
à cette tribune qui évoque peu ce sujet
d'un report de paris explique
aujourd'hui votre présence le ministre
en réalité déjà prend de la distance
l'ensemble du gouvernement prend de la
distance parce qu'on sent très bien que
ce sujet est un sujet délicat
c'est un sujet extrêmement délicat et je
comprends la prudence des autres
personnalités du gouvernement et je
regrette qu'on ait choisi une chef
d'entreprise comme vous pour ne pas nous
apporter aucun argument dans vos propos
préliminaires
deuxièmement il s'est passé un certain
nombre d'événements depuis le débat en
première lecture
il ya eu le cahier des charges c'est
vrai qu'il est éminemment faible pouvoir
ridicule ça a été très bien dit le
parrain à mes collègues tout à l'heure
un cahier des charges qui ne tient
absolument pas compte des besoins des
collectivités territoriales et des
départements il y a une
l'intrusion de l'état néerlandais auprès
de la compagnie air france qui est le
principal utilisateur de la plateforme
aéroportuaire et là on a vu le
gouvernement et le ministre nous tenir
des propos totalement différent en
disant que comme c'était une intrusion
que c'est inélégant qu'on ne comprenait
pas pourquoi parce que la compagnie elle
était stratégique
l'arpp on ne l'est pas mais la compagnie
est stratégique
enfin il verra le renouvellement du
président par le chef de l'état qui a
confirmé qu' il y aurait eu un troisième
mandat pour le président actuel
alors pour une société qui est mal gérée
ça pose peut-être quelques incertitudes
quelques problèmes si l'état est
insatisfait du président pourquoi le
renouveler ce sont que trois éléments
mais l'élément le plus important
peut-être il est cette semaine dans le
journal investir où il ya un interview
du président roh mané qui explique les
projets d'aéroports de paris
il les explique très bien similaire
d'investissements d'ici 2025
l'ouverture du terminal 4 la volonté de
le commercialiser de 60 mille mètres
carrés à 80 mille mètres carrés les
commerces la volonté tout simplement de
passer vers l'international de 281
millions de passagers à 400 millions de
passagers d'ici 2025 c'est-à-dire 10% du
temps de la concession que vous voulez
donner
et puis les 350 hectares avec un million
cinq cent mille mètres carrés de
constructibilité tout ça c'est dans le
journal investir de cette semaine 2
samedi dernier se doit pas être un
journal très révolutionnaire d'enfin il
doit être sérieux quant aux
préconisations
alors il ya une notion dur
chers collègues je finis monsieur le
président yann notions sur le cours de
l'action
et les vocations c'est il nous paraît
inconcevable que la privatisation puisse
se faire au cours actuel la valeur avec
un ami qu de l'entreprise est largement
supérieure je crois que tout est dit et
pour terminer aussi compte tenu de la
faiblesse des propos tenus par le
gouvernement je me rallierai
probablement à la solution référendaire
pour obliger l'état à écouter les
citoyens